can you talk to us a little bit about
stress um
stress is something that plagues a lot
of people there's a there's an
intellectual awareness that it's a
problem but
people feel paralyzed to fix it it's
like a train that's just run off the
tracks like you've lost control so what
are what are the best ways to combat
stress um
from starting point like you know
something that they can people can do
today and then something that may take a
little bit more time a little bit more
effort
uh
i'll put it this way
remember i did the analogy of the cup
that's filling up and once it fills up
it creates disease
um
and i mentioned that the two
determinants of the size of your cup
right you can have a 64-ounce glass and
i can i just have a shot glass
the size of a cup is determined by
genetics and stress
so
you can't change your genetics
but but stress can actually start
modifying the size of my shot class so
just if i'm less stressed less stress
the glass gets bigger and bigger and
bigger right so that cup
will always be
half to 75 full if you have emotional
suppression so even if you have
if you have emotional suppression and i
don't but you have a 64 ounce glass and
i only have a shot glass
in reality yours can be the size of shot
glass if you have an emotional
suppression so to empty truly truly
empty your cup
you need to release that emotion that is
stuck in the body now some people aren't
ready for that right some people come
into the office here and they go i'm i'm
really scared i don't know i don't know
and i go i bring them back i said listen
this is your body healing right there's
nothing to be scared of you you feel
emotions that need to be felt and then
they leave and then you have a new
relationship with them but first start
off with rituals
take time to yourself
and i know you have kids and i know
there's a lot of moms out there even
single moms out there single dads
right and you go when when when they
fall asleep and then i crash right but
do it in the shower then you take a
shower right you have some time in the
shower if you have five minutes in the
shower
in that moment be really mindful of the
water hitting your skin be really
mindful of how the soap is stunting on
your body be really mindful of your
fingers and your hair those type of
things are bringing you back and your
cortisol is going down in that very
moment
we go back to the sun
if you are
able to within an hour of waking up
going outside putting your feet on the
ground
trying to put your feet on even if you
live in new york city finding a patch of
grass if not seeing the sun that's going
to set up your cortisol awakening
response that's going to shoot up your
cortisol in a good way and then it's
going to come down it's going to put
your body stress
in rhythm right and then of course at
the end of the day getting good sleep if
you ain't getting good sleep you're go
your stress is going to be high for the
next day your day starts actually the
night before if you set yourself up for
good sleep your stress is going to be
lower the next day and then when i go
back to rituals being mindful but also
trying to meditate i know you have
issues meditating and getting in your
body i have a lot of issues
but then do do some guided meditation
guided have someone guide it at least
vocally to bring you into your body or
one type of meditation that really uh i
tell a lot of people who go who are here
and you can imagine how many people in
emotional release are like am i doing
this right is this breathing right doc
or oh no i feel it all in my head you
got to come back in your body one
exercise that i do is just bring
awareness lay down take 10 minutes bring
awareness to your toe
then to the your your knuckles uh bring
or or the or your the arch of your foot
your ankle your heel work your way up
all the way to your knee to your hips to
your stomach to your chest to your ears
to the top of your head if you just can
feel the sensation and when you bring
awareness you can feel it right if i say
bring awareness to your toe right now
jedidiah your big toe your right one you
can kind of feel a little tingling
that's awareness
do it around your whole body every
single inch of your body
the more you do that the more you start
becoming in touch with your body so if
you're i'm like you i'm here a lot right
i love like making sense of the world
and and thinking a lot but for people
like us and i know a lot of people
listening and viewing you got to make
sure that you get into your body daily
and this practice is really great at
grounding you people like us need more
grounding so things like this practice
if you can't meditate yeah then do this
you don't have to sit in silence just
actively feel in silence it's going to
be very important if you like the short
clip you can catch another one here or
you can catch the full episode right
here
[Music]